basically ready Ignacio do you want to
kick off our panel
thanks David so it's my pleasure to
introduce the panelists tonight or this
morning and so it's I trunk from MIT
John Martinez from University of
California Santa Barbara John press kill
from Cal Tech and Thomas Vedic also from
Cal Tech and so I will start with a
general maybe statement about the topic
of the this workshop namely quantum
devices simulation supremacy and
optimization so so I mean there have
been very interesting it's a result even
the last year is from the point of view
of the experiments and quantum computing
and so we have the first part on
computers that have demonstrated quantum
supremacy so my first question would be
would it be like a first step into
building a scalable quantum computer or
is it more already that we have to enjoy
that we have these misc devices and that
we have to learn from them and that
maybe will help shoot post and start
just investigating what you can do it
with them so maybe we can start with Ike
I not sure that's a rhetorical question
if I've ever heard one from you I mean
John Martinez should really respond to
whether we have a real quantum computer
or not but clearly we don't have a
useful quantum computer I don't think
anybody will disagree with the fact that
our current quantum computers are not
economically useful they don't yield
anything of economic value
now whether they're scientifically
interesting or not it's a completely
different matter clearly these machines
in different contexts are allowing us to
do precision measurements that we could
not have done a number of years ago and
I think that's very exciting for for
physics but it's not quite so inside
exciting enough for quantum computing
I think you framed the question as is
there a trade-off between using the
existing technology to seek interesting
applications or pushing ahead towards
more scalable devices of course I want
to do both on the algorithmic side we're
now entering the era of quantum tourist
extry have a very firm basis for
expecting speed ups for problems we care
about in the near term but it's very
important and instructive to try and to
have a dialogue between the computer
scientists and the algorithms and
potential users part of the challenging
from a theory challenging from a theory
point of view is that we want to
understand better the effect of noise on
computational power and from a
complexity or complexity theory point of
view that's a somewhat unusual question
because we don't to consider as
emphatically large depth if we have some
fixed error rate and width and there's
some optimal depth where it becomes
maximally hard to simulate classically
and that means we're really talking
about relatively low depth circuits and
trying to understand how powerful they
are and we heard a lot of interesting
results about that at at this meeting
for from Arum and and Sergey and Robert
and tougher men and so that's an
important direction for the theory
community to keep pressing on and as far
as fault tolerance is concerned I think
it's really important and it's going to
be a lot of fun and really interesting
to see how successfully we can use error
correction to make a stable quantum
memory in the near term and on a small
scale do fault tolerant gates we like to
see whether methods like randomize
compiling or effective in real devices
whether we can characterize noise well
enough to predict how well fault
tolerant methods will perform like John
Woolman talked about in his talk and
you know that's we can't leave that
behind because it's so important for the
future of the field
thank you John saw John Martinez yes
thank you
um slightly disagree with it-- wrong in
the sense that the quantum supremacy
experiment was economically useful
because we convinced Google executives
that this wasn't some physics pipe dream
but actually might work and thus they
supported the quantum group much better
and I think it was very important to
show that the basic physics worked even
at a large scale of you know effective
parallel computation and I think there's
gonna be more and more interest in this
from they say a Silicon Valley and in
other kind of kind of views that you
know this really may work from an
engineering point of view and they don't
have to take the word of physicists
anymore I think that's important
um one of the things I'd like to talk
about is going beyond quantum supremacy
I started thinking about how we have the
scale up of course the big issue is
getting the errors down to about 0.1%
and maybe few of our qubits are close to
that but clearly there's needs to be
work there but what happened over last
summer is I figured out pathway
distance' a hundred thousand or a
million cubits and then over the year I
was actually solving some technical
problems to get there so that I think
there's a pathway to get there where
they say pathway I don't mean you know
100 percent sure we're gonna get there
that I could outline exactly what you
you need to do and what I'm doing now is
taking my knowledge from that and I want
to go look at other Kubik technologies
and see if there are other a similar
pathways where you know you really know
what to do and and look at that
seriously so for me it's an interesting
time to
look at that clearly though we have to
make lower error qubits in order to do
error correction and potentially to do
Niska the numbers there are maybe 10 to
minus 3 to 10 to minus 4 errors that
you're gonna need but you know we have
to keep working on it
Thomas so you're asking me if we're
goin't and also about a little bit so
what is so the moment we have this nice
so and there is this perspective to
building this scalable quantum computer
so how do you see the situation what are
your interests or more the interesting
from that computer science community I
think from the point of view of computer
science we're waiting a little bit so
I'd kind of agree with Sean Presque Isle
that the devices that we have now are
not that interesting from a computer
science point of view there is maybe the
number of qubits is scaling up and you
can do these supremacy experiments but
the level of noise that we're seeing is
way beyond anything that could be useful
from an algorithmic point of view so I
think my perspective is that I find the
proof of principle is interesting but
I'm from my point of view I still have 5
or at the minimum 5 years to go before
there's anything - probably more like 10
years anything to play with ok so now
I'm going to launch some questions so
whoever wants to answer just start
speaking so the first is do you think
that is it important to further improve
the river of supremacy achievements of
the word to improve the river of
supremacy achievements of course it is I
mean actually one of the most
interesting things I did in the last few
weeks was to read the old papers of
Shafi gold roster and mccallion River
and in fact they were investigating
their own versions of supremacy years
ago for signatures in cryptography this
was seeking supremacy of a computational
complexity in nature and that was
remarkably productive for today's
society and so if we have such rigorous
bounds on quantum computation or hybrid
of quantum and classical or other
scenarios it can be nothing but very
interesting and and fundamentally useful
for us in the in the future I think
Thomas might agree with that actually
I'm not sure so I I don't know exactly
what you're referring to in terms of
their work because rigor of the
supremacy experiments is a little bit
it's kind of almost a self-defeating
statement because you're trying to prove
rigorously some finite sized
demonstration and so I think some some
of the work that has gone into that has
been interesting from the point of view
of complexity theory average case
hardness understanding the role of noise
I think all of these are interesting
questions um but fundamentally I don't
think that it's vital or crucial that we
have a supremacy experiment that is
fully rigorous maybe just because that's
impossible and by the time we get there
we'll be doing more interesting things
will be running algorithms will be
having interactive protocols will be
doing maybe quantum cryptography will be
doing actual simulations and so the
question of supremacy will be moot I
think it's like starting the question
theoretically is definitely leading to a
lot of interesting work but I don't
think it's a crucial target in itself to
to have something that's fully wiggers I
think it's important not just for
validating supremacy per se but because
it you know because of what comes out of
it because of the questions that theory
community addresses as a result and you
know coming up with better ways to
validate that a quantum computer is
performing the way we wanted to is
certainly important for the field and
like I said earlier we really want to be
able to say more firm
things about the computational value of
device that's noisy and you know
supremacy has provided invitation to
investigate those issues more seriously
yeah thank you John I appreciate that
yeah and we're looking forward to people
you know looking at or experiment
looking at other things more deeply I I
kind of think that the concept of
looking at complexity computational
complexity of a problem is quite an
interesting idea and which is of course
something we did for the quantum
supremacy experiment and I'll just throw
out an idea that kind of I think about I
don't know if it's correct but thinking
about quantum complexity is way more
interesting than thinking about quantum
entanglement I understand quantum
entanglement is very important for
quantum computing and the like but maybe
we're at the point now where things are
complicated enough and big enough and
systems are complicated that complexity
computational complexity is maybe
something we should be looking more and
more into just an idea I want to
continue this for a second if I may
Ignacio because perhaps the difference
between Thomas and I might be the
definition of rigor and what I'm
interpreting you're in intent of rigor
is is understanding the clarity of the
relationship of the parties and how the
protocol is structured not knowing a
precise number of where you can say if
there is going to be supremacy or not
supremacy and maybe here's an example so
in these old papers by gold cross
certainly reversed and by Andrew Yau I
was really enjoying the yellow seventies
papers when he was at Berkeley was it
was he a student then but he had and
they came up with rigor about the
relationship between the roles of the
people and the vigor of understanding
how the protocols interfaced and here's
my example today we have two very
different kinds of protocols one using
trapdoor claw free functions and another
using rigidity of magic squared
protocols one of them certifies
quantumness in saying that the two
participants have a shared entanglement
the other certifies the quantumness in
the ability to form a unitary transform
and yet both are certifying quantumness
and and something is strange about
having two different ways of doing it
maybe they're related
maybe fundamentally what we need in
order to rigorously understand what's
happening is to say realize that and
this is an idea I'm toying with it may
not be true but this illustrates I hope
where there's freedom that in a world of
free teleportation let's say we know
that we can turn States into gates and
vice versa and so maybe gcf's and the
rigidity of magic squares training sheet
to each other with that kind of a
relatively relative Oracle yeah so if
you finally formulated this way then I
definitely have to agree so I do find
these these questions interesting
they're questions about what are the
minimal assumptions that you need to put
in in your system or the interaction
that you have with it in order to gain
some kind of leverage about though or
some kind of information about all of
the results and how they have they have
been obtained and in it I think it's
true that these are probing pretty deep
into what's special about quantum
mechanics and the devices that we're
building and it's really we have it's
interesting what you're saying and
there's these few different frameworks
that rely on a few different types of
assumptions and that provides slightly
somewhat incomparable results okay thank
you somebody let's move on so a question
for I think that for John press kill is
we learn some fundamental physics with
Niska machines is there any hope for and
learn anything about what sir
fundamental physics Oh fundamental
physics eventually I'm sure we will I'm
sure we will but maybe you're asking
about how long it's going to take so
maybe can you elaborate on
why do you think that the drill oh well
okay well the thing that interests me
the most is the potential of getting
insight into quantum gravity from
quantum computation that's not
necessarily something we can do in the
mascara unless we're really lucky but
it's just not it's not a ridiculous idea
because thanks to the string theorists
who developed the idea of they call a
DSC Ft duality we understand that full
quantum theory of gravity has an
alternative description which doesn't
involve gravity at all which we can
simulate we hope eventually using a
quantum platforms and what's kind of
exciting is that recently we've seen
that that type of duality can apply to
quite simple systems I like what people
call the syk model the K or stands for
Kataya
which is really just a system of fermion
modes interacting without any geometric
locality constraints but has a very nice
geometrical description and terms a
black hole what worries me about doing
things like that in the NISS kara is the
things we're interested in are probably
very noise sensitive in the Newell
script in the dual description so I'm
not sure how how robust they'll be in in
real experiments but what's kind of cool
is that we've been seeing you can kind
of turn things around and phenomena
which look very complicated to
understand from the quantum platform
point of view can be simpler to
understand conceptually from the
gravitational point of view so some
version of teleportation that involves
the complicated scrambling phenomenon
and unscrambling has a very natural
description in terms of information
propagating through a traversable
wormhole and I think experimentally
exploring that kind of thing will give
us powerful tools for understanding
complex
I don't know and will eventually teach
us things about quantum gravity and
we'll be able to with quantum computers
simulate non perturbative effects that
are probably too hard to simulate
otherwise but there's a very interesting
cautionary note which is an important
contribution from the CS community of
this recent work by Boland pfefferman
and masrani where they pointed out that
the dictionary relating the
gravitational and non-gravitational
descriptions might for some purposes be
computationally complex things we'd
really like to know like what's going
inside of black holes like at the
singularity might be very hard to access
because of a complexity barrier in terms
of the alternative non gravitational
description and that's an important
thing to clarify where I think the
computer scientists could really make a
contribution I wanted to mention that
the quantum supremacy experiment shows
that quantum mechanics still works have
a hilbert space of 10 to the 16 which
about 10 to 13 times bigger than we ever
knew before so you know physics is
always pushing the frontier of where we
know physics can be applied and
certainly everyone thought that quantum
mechanics would work as we scale up but
I would say that's a piece of knowledge
about nature and quantum mechanics that
we gained recently and I think it's
important that it works if we want to
i'll practically move together on this
field so I think that's I want to follow
in John's same thread and observe or try
to observe on behalf of my colleagues in
condensed matter physics that not all
fundamental physics is about high-energy
physics and with all due respect John
the maybe you could say that Anderson
localization is fundamental and one of
the things that piques my interest and
this ties together with your comment
John might be
we don't understand no easy quantum
systems in a fundamental way and I would
really love to understand noisy quantum
systems and have fundamental theorems
about them kind of like anderson
localization talks about that kind of a
disordered system yeah and I and I kind
of agree because um one of the things
that actually surprised me a lot with
the quantum supremacy data was how we
could have a very simple noise
description under you know under the
certain approximations or things that we
did in the experiment and I was kind of
surprised that it works so well and
think it would be good to think about
that some more and also in terms of
Anderson localization our group I don't
know if it's it's been published yet did
some nice experiments on that as well as
other groups and it's a very nice piece
of fundamental physics that quantum
computers can investigate really well I
don't want to get hung up on the word
fundamental let's just say physics and I
think quantum platforms will be great
tools for physics discovery and that in
the near term probably the best
potential is to see dynamical phenomena
and many body systems that we haven't
had a handle on before and you know that
can be pretty exciting and I would
emphasize that that doesn't necessarily
mean circuit based corn computers it
could also they could mean analog
quantum simulators as well where we're
already seeing very interesting results
and analog simulations of dynamics
actually a very interesting analog
simulation I'm sorry an analog system
not resemble a ssin and I think you'd
agree with this
both John's is precision measurement
that probes fundamental physics I don't
mean to dwell on fundamental but
interesting physics like the change of
variation of fundamental constants oh
darn it I use the word again
but this is increasingly being possible
made possible by the harnessing of
entangled atomic systems that probe
things due to the entanglement of
degrees of freedom and maybe even with
molecule
as well I like to try to count that as
quantum information science especially
these atomic clocks that use two ions
and logic spectroscopy and I bet that
they will increasingly use ideas from
computer science to make such
fundamental such measurements possible
less in other settings the key thing is
to understand what are really the
classically hard things that we can
learn from the quantum platform so we
don't have other ways of learning and in
the case of dynamics that's not so
obvious because if you have systems that
are disordered and highly localized
maybe they're not so entangled and not
inaccessible classically and when
they're very strongly chaotic they just
converge the thermal equilibrium and
then it doesn't seem like anything
interesting happens but I think nature
is has great potential to reveal secrets
as we study dynamics in a regime where
we've never been able to before we have
to right ask the right questions
actually the trick is in the thing that
you just said is not always true of
course there are perhaps thermalized
systems or systems that are thermal
izing which may nevertheless contain an
enormous amount of entanglement as long
as you look at it in the right way and
maybe this is what is actually behind
that slowing down behavior that happens
that prevents thermalization pre
formalization behavior experiments can
help us to understand those things right
so let me remind the audience that you
can use the Q&A not that you have you
want to ask some questions as well but
in the meantime let me answer this
question and it's also about
applications of these quantum computers
so can we expect for any fundamentally
new algorithm or algorithmic approach so
maybe Thomas can start here
so do you mean can we expect to develop
new quantum algorithms in the future not
necessarily for the current job I think
we can I think there is sort of a
pessimistic or blase view that says that
you know shows algorithm is the only
algorithm that we ever discovered that's
very wrong I think I would expect I
would think that quantum algorithms is
still filled that's it in its infancy
I expect that the new devices that are
being built will be useful in develop
developing quantum algorithms so things
like the QA away algorithm that we heard
a lot about this is very poorly
understood maybe it's a useful algorithm
maybe it's not we'll learn that as we
use it and this might give us ideas as
to how to analyze it I think more
broadly for example quantum
approximation algorithms is is something
that that's very not developed I don't I
know barely any quantum algorithm that
has approximation guarantees as opposed
to an algorithm that returns an exact
solution in the field of classical
algorithms this is incredibly developed
and it only developed sort of at a late
stage when people invented linear
programming semi definite programming
and decided I think that's one possible
direction where things would develop but
I think even for fundamental problems
like crypto motivated problems lattices
I don't think you know it maybe ten
years of research in that direction is
is almost nothing given the complexity
of the problem so I do expect many
discoveries in the next ten years or so
well I hope when we can really run
quantum computers that will stimulate
new algorithmic discoveries certainly
change the game Ignacio I was smiling
because I was wondering you know in the
early days of classical computers a
panel like this might have existed where
you might have said is there any hope
now that we have discovered the greatest
common devisor algorithm for more
algorithms and as you know today what
has happened is the major classical
computer algorithms are things like
MapReduce and rank
pruning PageRank and these these
completely change the notion of what an
algorithm was because it became
distributed
there's so little work on distributed
quantum algorithms today you know and
and it's more like protocols and not
just algorithms because there are
adversarial relationships that
extraordinarily rich that can be
envisioned like one of the most
important classical algorithms today is
called the taxes algorithm and I know
many of us know this one we use it daily
it's probably being used for the
underlying database that makes possible
the synchronization of this zoom system
and and what is quantum Paxos you you
know these are really beautiful
questions that still lie open to be
answered
I could I could read a question from
from the attendees from anonymous but I
think an interesting thing to talk about
do you
I think the you perhaps means all
panelists perhaps have any thoughts or
beliefs on the future ability of
measurement based or cluster state
quantum computation to compete with the
more traditional approaches that are
dominant currently who's interested in
that I'll just make a comment you know I
think that there's been a lot of
photonic quantum computing which I
assume is along these ideas and I would
like a method there's a big part of the
algorithm measuring the quantum states
maybe maybe not quite what you're
talking about but but I don't understand
this you know I don't really understand
the algorithm in the limits of how good
your measurements and all the elements
has to be that maybe I just need to sit
down and figure out that out but my part
of it is really understanding the system
requirements for these different
different proposals I agree with John
I think the right computational model to
think about depends on the features of
our hardware and if for example you know
we have a device where we can make
cluster states of many photons and by
measuring them do a computation and
that's going to be a powerful approach
and won't be the best way necessarily
with some other hardware platform I will
pile on and agree with both John's it's
hard to disagree with John squared but
it's kind of like measurement based
quantum computing or cluster computing
is an extremal point because it talks
about using only measurements but it
would be very very interesting to come
up with a rich variety which uses a
limited set of measurements together
with a limited set of noisy gates and we
don't know these kinds of trade-offs but
on behalf of computer science let me
also point out that one of the most
important things about measurement based
quantum computing is a modest beautiful
work where is she
bootstrap based on that and TCS to come
up with these extraordinary proofs about
fully homomorphic quantum encryption and
maybe the underlying concepts of
teleporting gates is going to arise over
and over again irregardless of whether
you call it cluster based computing or
not and in many different protocols okay
thanks
so I have a question for John Martinez
and so you mentioned that there seems to
be a past at least that you found the
past for scalability of this if a
quantum computer so is it a question now
of money of investment or let's have
like an AI filter or a CERN for quantum
computing let's try all us to work
together on that or it requires some
time and different places competing with
each other so what is what is the model
that you have in mind for that yeah the
most important part to the path is
actually figuring out how to get the
gain errors to about the 0.1% you know
initially if you're at point or point B
that's fine then use it better over time
that's fine and the nice thing about
condoms
premise e experiment it built a grid of
qubits so that you know that you're
testing it in a realistic way it's very
easy to test qubits in some simplified
way and think you're doing fine when you
scale up it doesn't when I set a path I
mean it's like you could figure out all
the technologies you have the bill and
in fact you know over December I or
important thing and it's just a matter
of getting everyone together in the
right environment to put that put that
together and yeah so so yeah maybe I
better have been say more than that so
maybe a related question but not from
the more theoretical point of view so do
you think that in the case of quantum
error correction so we have already
reached the best that we have or there
is a lot of room for improvement in
terms of overhead thresholds and so on
so in terms of the theory you're saying
no no I'm asking about a few right yeah
we don't even know what the threshold
for [ __ ] classical computing is
today so it's very hard to say we know
the end of the story for folklore and
quantum computation but I bet John is
rearing to answer this question so go
for it John I'm just saying the nice
thing is experiments and measure how
much better things that as you build it
bigger and bigger and you can measure
the space-time and do that so you know
we we can take the existing models and
see how we're doing and you know we're
hoping that people come up with even
better ideas or you know more maybe more
clever ways to do the architecture that
will help us we're kind of working
together experimentalists and theories
in order to improve it
oh yeah that that would be that would be
very good and and I think you know I
could mention this earlier that you know
once you
and maybe John that you know once you
kind of understand what your error
models are and what's going on
you can then figure out how to how to
build the system properly or maybe apply
the error correction so fortunately we
we know enough now to you know move
ahead in in the definite direction and
make progress and in validate if we're
doing properly but you know again as you
get data people should keep thinking
about how to make it better and you know
first that just for example the decoding
algorithm for the surface code is you
know that's a pretty hard thing to do to
get that to work fast and I think
there's a you know just I think it could
be a big effort for people multiple
groups to work on that I'm just sewn to
that piece of software to do it do it
efficiently you know for super adducting
qubits you're talking about a
supercomputer side size decoding a
classical computer to run alongside your
Quantico not quite the size of Summit
but you know a big computer and I think
there could be more effort and more work
to solve that problem which would be
good computer science and physics well
you know we've all seen the discouraging
overhead estimates even if we have a
gate error rate of 10 to the minus 3
came up in Alexander day I actually
worked by Mike and his collaborators and
Easton and Cannell and others emphasize
that there's kind of an obstacle to
getting a universal set of gates that
are fault tolerant for a quantum code
there been a lot of interesting new
ideas in the last couple of years about
how to achieve universality the
traditional answer has been magic state
distillation or there are other ideas
none of them have been game changers I
think there may be an opportunity for
theorists there that we don't really
have a very systematic way of thinking
about these things understanding the
different possible ways of getting a
universal fault-tolerance ID and if we
had more about a better theoretical
framework that might suggest new ideas
and then of course I also agree with the
philosophy Alex Jean had in his talk
that if we can you know put in some
protection at the device level perhaps
devices with highly biased noise we can
take advantage of that and that might
allow us to get to low logical error
rates sooner I also think that if you
start having experiments you know
starting to do more and more serious
error correction then that'll encourage
computer scientists and physicists that
look deeper at it because they'll see
that their ideas can be applied in a
reasonable amount of time so we have to
catch up on master
Ignazio I'd like to highlight a comment
by Eddie Fani in risk and and use that
to maybe partially respond to your last
question and then tie into what Martine
is just proposed that is that there
needs to be a greater effort eddie
exhorts us by saying you should
encourage people to work on quantum
approximate optimization algorithms
where we have taken first steps and
there's a very nice sense here that
maybe what we need to do is to encourage
exploration with a metric that lets us
measure progress and in the computer
science community this is now done by
having competitions for example for
image search labeling machine learning
in cases where we don't actually have
any proofs of any performance bounds on
algorithms we could have the same kind
of thing we're almost reaching at the
stage at which maybe some quantum
computers could be used or maybe some
theoretical models could be employed to
allow there to be a leaderboard of
scores of approaches that solve
interesting relevant problems john and
john maybe this was addressed some of
the ideas that both be raised oh yes i
agree of course you have to be careful
what your metrics are and and you know
think about that tariff
but as you have more and more
experiments and your running algorithms
even in the nist era whatever then it
becomes a little bit more clear what the
proper metrics are that's good to good
to a pro so you know when you when you
write metrics for your laptop what is it
it was hundreds or thousands of metrics
on different programs to run and people
kind of take an average that so we have
to get started just a quick comment
about cue AOA and other variational
approaches you don't necessarily need
universal control to do it in an
interesting way if you have a device
like an ion trap or neutral atom system
which has its own native Hamiltonian
which is tunable then that might give
you access to an interesting set of
variational state so that's a another
approach that we're going to be
exploring I hope in the next few years
yeah and Misha Lukens beautiful
presentation highlighted how this is
done for river gardens and so you may
pretend much tighter involvement of
theory with physical evolution of our
nature we haven't actually seen in
classical computation for a long time
there used to be this notion that we
would manipulate analog degrees of
freedom to do classical computation of
course all that has gone away so maybe
part of this will be both the classical
dynamics and the quantum dynamics of
these systems that you mentioned John
well in the long run digital you know is
more scalable and it's more flexible in
the Hamiltonians
you can simulate and the and the state
preparations you can do but in the near
term I think analog is very promising to
explore yeah vacuum tube computer has
lasted and helped the United States in
the world for many years there's a
question from Debbie Leung she asks now
that experiments have advanced
significantly recently do we have some
ideas how the physical noise may change
as we scale up the computation so that's
definitely a physics question maybe more
unitary and less stochastic I don't know
what what do you guys
well I'm just gonna say in the quantum
supremacy experiment we were concerned
about this and by you know engineering
things very very carefully in terms of
crosstalk and whatever in the end our
noise model was what we measured with
one or two qubits and kind of you know
understood and on that slope I was kind
of pleasantly but Leslie surprised that
there wasn't any obvious new physics
going on of course we have to continue
to look for that but that's that's good
news but you know you'd have to look at
each system to see if something
unexpected appears and of course once
you start doing error correction and you
can look for multi order errors which
are not really seen in the Condors
experiment you know you have to check
for that and again well as John said the
Google experiment admits a very simple
model of how the you know circuit
fidelity scales with the circuit size
and maybe the part of the reason for
that is that those random circuits were
such good scramblers of quantum
information which turned the noise into
something very simple and we don't know
how well that will apply to more
structured algorithm so that'll be an
interesting thing to learn about yeah
and in you know my thought is you can
always apply kind of spin a queen in
kind of randomized Monaca we the
generalization echoey to mitigate some
of the correlated errors you might see
and that's certainly what the quantum
supremacy does and what you would do for
a full error corrected quantum computer
it's using lock-in techniques
essentially it was very well known
experimental idea but we have to see if
those work we have to see if there's new
mechanisms subtle things going on so
yeah they're there so there's a lot of
research to do there to understand it's
really a good question important thing
to do I like I like Debbie your question
a lot and actually I want to turn it
around and suggest a challenge to
Martinez which is could you then
instead of random using random Polly's
and so forth to get rid of the noise or
mitigated reconstruct your algorithm and
circuit to accentuate it so that you can
figure out exactly what kind of
correlated noise might exist because
there might be unexpected and very
interesting when we go to tune up the
devices you run sequences to accentuate
noise to see what's going on and then
you can tune in your control parameters
to do that so yes yet for example when
you have control errors you can really
minimize your control errors by
extension essentially this is what eight
Debbie play those trips John what Debbie
is telling you is that maybe you should
investigate your noise much more closely
it's not the first time a Nobel Prize
has been hidden in that noise yes that
would be that's great and yeah I agree
and I think what will be interesting is
when the Google team you know gets the
device out on the cloud then people can
propose to do things and it would be
very interesting to get many many people
thinking about about that and learn from
that so that's that's key so this is
getting really interesting we're way
over time as compared to the program so
I think that maybe it's time to wrap up
so maybe want to hear a statement about
the now the meeting about the progress
or about whatever you have in mind from
each of you and then I think that we
will close the session so we can start
alphabetically maybe we psych yeah just
one very brief comment I'm ever so
grateful to the Symons Institute for
bringing this together because one of
the neatest things I found was this
interface between computer science and
physicists being really celebrated but
it's bringing both crowds together and
many of these quantum meetings I'm
finding one or the other and not the
combination maybe it was an accident of
having the loudest people at the same
time but it was truly nice to see that
and I think that one of the weakest
wheels in the
quantum computing like machinery right
now is getting computer science spun up
to be really truly invested in this
whole process so thank you to the sinus
Institute and I hope many other folks
also share this perspective I think so I
think that everybody shares so the next
one maybe John Martinez I'm just gonna
say I think things are quite vibrant and
exciting right now and we're just gonna
keep on going
for the next five or ten years doing
great experiments and let's just you
know see where we go here it's it's it's
it's really in some sense opening up or
or continuing to be a very vibrant feel
young John Prisco well just building on
what I said the Symons Institute is a
great gift to the theory community and
part of what makes it so valuable is it
has a very high profile online and I as
someone who had planned to come to
Berkeley but whose plans were dashed
like I'm sure many others have very much
appreciated being able to follow what's
going on throughout the program through
that online presence and I think part of
the legacy of this program can be
showing how successful online events can
be this is the second workshop that
transitioned to an all zoom format and
those were two very successful workshops
and I'm grateful for all involved who
made that happen
so month well medium flip around John
and Ikes comments and say thank you to
all the physicists who joined us at the
assignments for for this semester and
accepted to agree to engage with the
computer scientist and share their ideas
this is particularly true for this for
this last workshop so I think it's we've
received great response and it's great
to indeed have the Symons Institute help
us attract
and come and give talks so since since
I'm last meet maybe I'll also tank a lot
of the organizers so first the
organizers of this workshop so Ignacio
de vida and Barbara thanks a lot for
putting this together
in spite of the difficult circumstances
and getting such a great lineup of
speakers we had a very very large
attendance I think this week it's it's
impressive with the talks had then you
were between 100 and 200 participants
logged in and many hundreds more
watching the stream and then and then
offline so thanks a lot to the
organizers and the speakers
I also thank organizers of the other
workshops that we've had so let me not
name everyone but but but thanks thanks
to everyone um also the co-organizers of
the whole semester so under child's
Ignacio she hug and I knew much was
there ani thanks a lot home for helping
or putting this together and yeah as I
can and John said already thanks to the
science institute for hosting us for a
great if turbulent semester and thanks
to the leadership Peter Paul Fletcher
people buzzer all the way to the
technical staff staff who meet who's who
still with us then actually who was a
little bit ago and and all the others so
thanks everyone thank you thank you very
much so thank all the panelists and
[Music]
evening here in Europe May morning is
there in the US so maybe I passed the
work to David to say directly in the
last comments oh well I don't have so
much I would have I would love to have
hugged the entire panel discussion and
asked my own questions
you know how the how the million cubits
are really going to work and I always
have my black hole questions for John
press kill but we'll have to save that
for another day I'm glad that Josh Bazar
on he still has his camera open so we
can actually see what it looks like
there in in California I feel a very
strong sense of envy that I and that I
missed my two weeks in California but
anyway thanks to all of you for your
comments and for participating and I
think that's all I have to say
Barbara's the only one who hasn't had
last word you want to say something
Barbara
yeah we're we're all welding a little
bit of buzzing walk actually let's take
an evening walk okay it was great
alright and Eddie far he says enjoy your
remarks stay healthy Eddie bye so good
last word okay bye bye bye everybody